This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the Olympic Games in 2021, one athlete arrived in Tokyo with a mountain of expectations on her 4'8 inch frame. 5 medals in real, 4 of them gold and could do even better than that this time around here in Tokyo. If you don't think that that's hard, then you really don't understand gymnastics. People didn't just expect her to win gold medals in gymnastics. They expected magic.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在2021年奥林匹克运动会上，一位运动员带着如山的期望踏上了东京的土地，她那4尺8寸（约1.42米）的身躯承载着这一切。在现实中曾获得5枚奖牌，其中4枚是金牌，这次在东京她本可以做得更好。如果你认为这并不难，那你真的是一点也不了解体操。人们不仅仅期望她在体操项目中赢得金牌。他们期望的是奇迹。
She has just set herself so far apart from the rest of the field and not just on the converse. We're on the field! Look at this! We're gonna be in high-fascet! And finals pursue a history of history starts tonight. Four days into the games, Simone Biles pulled out of the competition. I've just never felt like this going into a competition before and I tried to go out here and have fun and warm up in the back when a little bit better but then once I came out here I was like no, mental is not there. The world was stunned and athlete with seemingly other worldly powers was struggling.
她将自己与同场竞技的其他人拉开了极大的差距，而且不仅仅是在平衡木上。我们就在现场！看这个！我们将以全景特写呈现！决赛正在追逐一段历史，而这段历史今晚就要拉开帷幕。在比赛开始四天后，西蒙娜·拜尔斯退出了比赛。我以前参加比赛时从来没有过这种感觉，我试着去场上享受乐趣，在后台热身时稍微好一点，但一旦我来到场上，我就想，不行，我的精神状态不在状态。全世界都惊呆了，这位拥有仿佛超凡脱俗能力的运动员正在苦苦挣扎。
From the outside looking in it seemed hard to understand and it raised a question. If a world champion can be toppled by these emotions, what does it mean for the rest of us? This week on Hidden Brain, in the latest in our success 2.0 series, we examine the voice inside our heads that says, the world may think you are amazing, but you're really afraid. It's hard to see ourselves clearly. This is true in all manner of situations, but it can be especially true when we are confronting a challenge. At such moments, many of us start to doubt ourselves. We think we are unequal to the task.
从局外人的角度来看，这似乎很难理解，这也引发了一个问题：如果连世界冠军都能被这些情绪所击倒，那对我们其他人意味着什么呢？本周的《隐藏的大脑》栏目，在我们“成功2.0”系列节目的最新一期中，我们将探讨我们内心深处的声音，这个声音在说：世人可能觉得你很了不起，但其实你内心非常恐惧。看清自己很难。在各种情况下这都是事实，而当我们面对挑战时，尤其如此。在这样的时刻，我们许多人开始自我怀疑。我们认为自己无法胜任这项任务。
At the University of Michigan, Kevin Cochley researchers the psychology of self-doubt. He studies the corrosive effects these doubts can have on our well-being, but also how we might turn our internal misgivings into an ally. Kevin Cochley, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Kevin, you're a psychologist who studies the phenomenon of self-doubt, but you yourself have not been immune to such doubts. I want to take you back to when you were 29 years old.
在密歇根大学，凯文·科克利研究自我怀疑的心理学。他研究这些疑虑可能对我们的幸福感带来的侵蚀性影响，同时也研究我们如何将内心的不安转化为盟友。凯文·科克利，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。凯文，你是一位研究自我怀疑现象的心理学家，但你自己也未能幸免于这种疑虑。我想带你回到你29岁的时候。
You had just completed your PhD, you had begun teaching. Can you describe the fears that went through your mind as you prepared for class each day? Yes, I was a young assistant professor at Southern Illinois University at Carbondale and I can recall very vividly the feeling that I had walking the hallways at the psychology department there and seeing on the walls these publications by my new colleagues, very accomplished colleagues. And I had come out of graduate school having only one publication.
你刚刚完成了博士学位，并开始执教。你能描述一下你每天准备上课时，脑海中闪过的恐惧吗？是的，当时我是南伊利诺伊大学卡本代尔分校的一名年轻助理教授，我能清晰地回忆起当时我在那里的心理学系走廊里走着的感觉，看到墙上挂着我的新同事们——那些非常有成就的同事们的出版物。而我刚从研究生院出来，只有一篇出版物。
I believed that I was hired on the basis that people saw potential in me, particularly in terms of my teaching. But I knew that I had a lot to prove in terms of research. And so when I was walking those hallways, I had this sense of wow, like, can I do this? And it was incredibly stressful.
我相信我被录用是因为人们看到了我的潜力，特别是在教学方面。但我知道，在研究方面我有很多东西需要证明。所以当我在那些走廊里走的时候，我有一种“哇，我能做到吗？”的感觉，这压力大得难以置信。
It sort of had me doubting whether, in fact, I belonged, whether I deserve to be there. And I was aware that I was one of only a few black professors at the university. And so I did not want to do anything that would result in students seeing me or believing me to not be qualified to be the professor. So I made sure that I wore sports coats and wore ties to class every day. I had a briefcase that I bought because in my mind a professor carries a briefcase. And so I was really working hard to project an image of expertise and authority that I imagined professors needing to represent.
它让我怀疑自己是否真的属于这里，是否配得上待在那里。而且我知道我是这所大学里为数不多的黑人教授之一。因此，我不想做任何会导致学生认为或相信我不具备当教授资格的事情。所以我确保自己每天去上课时都穿着运动外套和领带。我买了一个公文包，因为在我的心目中，教授就得提着公文包。因此，我真的在努力塑造一种专家和权威的形象，我想象中教授们需要展现的那种形象。
I understand that one way yourself doubt manifested was that you were worried about misbeaking in class, saying something wrong. And I'm wondering when you imagine making a mistake like that, what was the worst-case scenario that ran through your head? Speaking in front of a large introductory class, psychology class, I thought, man, I cannot stand here and mispeak. I need to make sure that I'm conjugating, you know, my verbsak. I need to make sure that I'm conjugating,
据我了解，你的一种自我怀疑的表现是，你担心在课堂上说错话，讲错话。我想知道，当你想象自己犯了这样的错误时，在你脑海中闪过的最坏情况是什么？在一个大型的入门心理学班级前面发言，我想，天哪，我不能站在这里说错话。我需要确保我在动词变位，你知道的，我的动词。我需要确保我在动词变位，
you know, my verbs correctly. I need to make sure that I'm enunciating every word exactly correctly. And so for me, the worst case scenario would have been to be lecturing and to say something incorrectly. And then to have my students questioning my authority and ability to be an effective professor. And so for me, that was a worst case scenario.
你知道，我的动词用得对。我需要确保我字斟句酌，每个词都发音准确无误。所以对我来说，最坏的情况就是在讲课时说错了话。然后让我的学生质疑我的权威以及作为一名合格教授的能力。所以对我来说，那就是最坏的情况。
You've been a professor for a while now. You clearly know what you're doing. You have a lengthy publication record. Have yourself doubts gone away? You know, that's a good question. It depends on the day that you ask me the question. When I'm speaking to people and when people are introducing me and they're reading my accolades, on the one hand I feel pretty good about what I've been able to accomplish.
你当教授已经有一段时间了。你显然知道自己在做什么。你有着长长的发表记录。你的自我怀疑消失了吗？你知道，这是个好问题。这取决于你是在哪一天问我这个问题。当我向人们讲话时，当人们介绍我并宣读我的荣誉时，一方面，我对能够取得的成就感到相当满意。
But there are still some days when I find myself doubting what I have the expertise to be able to speak in front of people. When I talk to my students about this, they find it amazing because they have Dr. Kevin Cochley on somewhat of an academic pedestal. And when I tell them that even Dr. Cochley sometimes still suffers and still wonders about my deservedness to be in the position that I'm in, they are surprised.
但有时我还是会发现自己怀疑自己是否具备在众人面前发言的专业知识。当我跟我的学生谈到这一点时，他们觉得很不可思议，因为他们在某种程度上把凯文·科克利博士奉上了学术神坛。而当我告诉他们，甚至连科克利博士有时也依然饱受折磨，依然会怀疑自己是否配得上现在的位置时，他们都感到很惊讶。
So I do still have those experiences. So Kevin, it looks like you yourself are a walking example of this phenomenon that you have studied for many years. In popular culture, it's called the imposter syndrome. Now, you think that term is overly clinical. You prefer the term imposter phenomenon. Can you describe for me what the imposter phenomenon is? The imposter phenomenon is basically the sentiment that one is being intellectually fraudulent.
所以我确实仍然会有这些经历。那么，凯文，看起来你本人就是一个活生生的例子，展现了你研究多年的这种现象。在流行文化中，这被称为“冒名顶替综合征”。现在，你认为这个术语过于临床化了。你更喜欢“冒名顶替现象”这个词。你能为我描述一下什么是“冒名顶替现象”吗？“冒名顶替现象”基本上就是一种认为自己在智力上是个骗子的心态。
It's the idea that individuals who are very accomplished, very competent, very intelligent people, nevertheless feel like they are fooling people. They believe that they are not nearly as smart and competent as their accomplishments would suggest. So we're going to talk about the factors that produce these kinds of self-doubt and what we can do about these misgivings. But I want to start by looking at the different dimensions of self-doubt because when you start to peel this onion, it turns out to be a really complex phenomenon. I want to play you a clip of the actress Viola Davis talking to the CBS program 60 minutes. I don't know if it's healthy or not.
这就是这样一种观点：那些非常有成就、非常有能力、非常聪明的人，仍然觉得自己是在糊弄别人。他们认为自己远没有自己的成就所暗示的那样聪明和能干。所以我们将讨论产生这些自我怀疑的因素，以及我们能对这些不安做些什么。但我想先从自我怀疑的不同维度切入，因为当你开始剥开这层洋葱时，它原来是一个非常复杂的现象。我想放一段女演员维奥拉·戴维斯接受哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）节目《60分钟》采访的片段。我不知道这是否健康。
I'm just saying that it's something that I recognize and all the artists I've worked with. It's in all of them. So I know the language of the artist and the language of the artist is, someone's going to find me out. I may not be as great as people's think I am. I may not be as great as people think I am. So, one dimension of self-doubt here
我只是说这是我以及我合作过的所有艺术家都能认同的一点。他们所有人身上都有。所以我懂艺术家的语言，艺术家的语言就是：总有一天会有人发现我的底细。我可能没有别人想的那么伟大。我可能没有别人想的那么伟大。所以，自我怀疑的一个维度在这里
is that you worry that others might have an inflated sense of how good you are, that you might not be able to live up to those expectations. Yeah, that is one of the hallmarked traits of imposter feelings. When you have friends and colleagues telling you how great you are and saying all of these nice and wonderful things about you, you find yourself just wondering, can I live up to these lofty expectations and you can't help but sort of feel that I can't live up to that.
就是你会担心别人对你有多优秀有一种过高的估计，担心自己可能无法达到那些期望。是的，这是冒名顶替感觉的标志性特征之一。当你的朋友和同事告诉你你有多棒，对你赞不绝口时，你会发现自己不禁在想：我能达到这些崇高的期望吗？你情不自禁地会有一种感觉：我达不到那种高度。
So when Viola Davis made those remarks, it really sort of represented some of the classic hallmark signs of imposterism. So I'm wondering if this might be especially acute for an actor, but I think all of us might experience some version of this. When you're shooting a movie, they don't show the audience all the takes when someone flubbed a line or made a mistake. So Viola Davis thinks that we, you know, when you're shooting a movie, they don't show the audience all the takes when someone flubbed the line or made a mistake. So, Viola Davis thinks that we, the audience,
所以当维奥拉·戴维斯发表这些言论时，它确实在某种程度上代表了一些冒名顶替心态的经典标志性特征。所以我在想，这对于一个演员来说可能会尤为严重，但我认为我们所有人可能都经历过某种版本的这种心态。当你拍电影时，观众不会看到所有的拍摄镜头，不会看到某人台词说砸了或者犯了错误的时候。所以维奥拉·戴维斯认为我们，你知道的，当你拍电影时，观众不会看到所有的拍摄镜头，不会看到某人台词说砸了或者犯了错误的时候。所以，维奥拉·戴维斯认为我们这些观众，
associate her with the perfection of the roles she's playing on the screen, what we see on the screen, she, on the other hand, knows the whole picture, the, you know, all the mistakes, the off days, and she worries that our picture of her and her picture of her might not match. that our picture of her and her picture of her might not match. You are absolutely correct. What we see is the sort of perfected version of who she is as an actress. What we don't see are, as you said, the many outtakes, you know, I'm that I'm sure she's had to go through in order to get finally the perfect scene. Again, I mean, it's the idea that you know, one needs to try to be
把她和她在屏幕上扮演的角色的完美性联系在一起，我们在屏幕上看到的是这样，而另一方面，她自己知道全貌，你知道的，所有的错误、状态不佳的日子，她担心我们对她的看法和她对自己的看法可能并不匹配。我们对她的看法和她对自己的看法可能并不匹配。你完全说得对。我们看到的是她作为一名女演员的完美版本。我们看不到的是，正如你所说的那样，许多未被采用的镜头，你知道的，我确信她为了最终拍出完美的场景不得不经历这一切。再说一次，我的意思是，这就是那种你需要努力做到
perfect because you believe that people sometimes see you as being perfect when you know that to not be true about yourself. So why were the Davis was asked to play the role of Michelle Obama in a showtime series titled The First Lady. And she described Michelle Obama as a goddess. I want to look at the next dimension of self-doubt and play you a clip. Here is Michelle Obama talking about a question that goes through her own mind all the time. Am I good enough? That's a question that has dog me for a good part of my life. Am I good enough to have all of this? Am I good enough to be the first lady of the United States?
完美的想法，因为你相信人们有时会视你为完美，而你知道真实的自己并非如此。因此，当维奥拉·戴维斯被邀请在Showtime系列剧《第一夫人》中扮演米歇尔·奥巴马的角色时。她将米歇尔·奥巴马描述为一位女神。我想看看自我怀疑的下一个维度，并为你播放一段音频。这里是米歇尔·奥巴马在谈论一个始终在她脑海中盘旋的问题。我够优秀吗？这个问题在我大半生中一直困扰着我。我足够优秀以拥有这一切吗？我足够优秀能成为美国的第一夫人吗？
And I think that many women and definitely many young girls of all backgrounds walk around with that question. I still feel that at some level, I have something to prove because of the color of my skin, because of the shape of my body, because of who knows how people are judging me. So I feel like Michelle Obama is speaking to another dimension of self-doubt. And perhaps this is similar to your own experience
我想很多女性，当然还有许多来自各种背景的年轻女孩，脑子里都带着这个问题走来走去。我仍然觉得在某种程度上，因为我的肤色，因为我的身材，因为谁知道别人是如何评判我的，我还有一些需要证明的东西。所以我觉得米歇尔·奥巴马是在谈论自我怀疑的另一个维度。也许这类似于你自己的经历
with self-doubt as a 29 year old assistant professor. And this one of self-doubt is not that other people think too highly of you, but the fear that other people might think that you're a fraud. Yeah, and I found myself smiling because that is the exact clip that I use in every imposter phenomenon talk that I give. I was actually saying the words along with her as she was saying it. But yeah, no, you're right.
作为一个29岁的助理教授时感到的自我怀疑。而这种自我怀疑不是别人觉得你太优秀了，而是担心别人可能会认为你是个骗子。是的，我不禁笑了出来，因为这正是我在每一次做关于冒名顶替现象的演讲时都会用的片段。她说话的时候，我其实也在跟着她一起说。但是，是的，没错。
In this instance, she's talking about the feelings of self-doubt that she has about herself, but that are really rooted in, I would argue, societal's views about people who look like her, people whom she would represent. Now, you might think that one form of self-defense against these feelings is to just simply prove to yourself that you're very good, but it turns out that doesn't always work. The poet Maya Angelou won three Grammys for her spoken word albums. She was nominated for the Pulitzer Prize for Poetry and won the presidential Medal of Freedom. If she had never written another word in her life, her reputation would have been secure.
在这种情况下，她谈论的是她对自己的自我怀疑的感觉，但我会认为，这实际上深深植根于社会对那些长相与她相似的人、她所代表的人的看法。现在，你可能会认为，抵御这些情绪的一种自我防御方式就是向自己证明你真的很优秀，但事实证明这并不总是奏效。诗人玛雅·安杰洛曾凭其口语专辑赢得三项格莱美奖。她曾获普利策诗歌奖提名，并荣获总统自由勋章。如果她一生中再没写过一个字，她的声誉也早已稳固。
But Maya Angelou was still plagued by self-doubt. She talks about having published 11 books and still finding herself wondering, uh-oh, they're gonna find me out. And when I talk about her, I say, look, she is Maya-Freakin' Angelo. She's one of the greatest fortices that we've ever experienced.
但玛雅·安杰洛仍然饱受自我怀疑的困扰。她谈到自己已经出版了11本书，却依然发现自己在想：“糟了，他们要发现我是个冒牌货了。”每当我谈到她时，我都说：“看，她可是大名鼎鼎的玛雅·安杰洛啊。她是我们经历过的最伟大的诗人之一。”
And yet, even Maya Angelo has had these feelings of being found out that she is somehow fraudulent and fooling people. And so, she is a beautiful example of someone who has achieved at the very highest level, nevertheless still feeling as though they are fraudulent. You know, I'm struck by the similarities between self-doubt and conspiracy theories. Go along with me for just a second here. On the surface, these are very different ideas, but one thing that unites them is that if you're played by self-doubt
然而，即便玛雅·安杰洛也有这种被人识破的感觉，觉得自己不知怎么的就是个骗子，在糊弄别人。因此，她是一个极好的例子：一个在最高水平上取得成就的人，内心仍然觉得自己是个骗子。你知道，自我怀疑和阴谋论之间的相似之处让我感到震惊。请陪我思考一秒钟。表面上，这些是截然不同的概念，但将它们联系在一起的一点是，如果你饱受自我怀疑的困扰
or you subscribe to a conspiracy theory, the evidence does not disobey you of your belief. So in the case of a conspiracy theory, you find ways to discount the evidence that contradicts the theory. And in the case of self-doubt, no amount of past evidence that you're talented seems to convince you that your fears are not warranted. No, I mean, that's absolutely right. In fact, it almost kind of reminds me of the social psychological concept or confirmation bias. You know, you are more oriented toward finding evidence that supports the contrary, that would support, you know, the idea of you not being competent, even though, again, your accomplishments would suggest otherwise. So I can actually see the connection. There's one last dimension of self-doubt that I want to place on the table. The actor Tom Hanks has
或者你笃信某种阴谋论，那么事实证据并不会打消你的信念。所以在阴谋论的情况下，你会寻找各种方法来贬低与该理论相矛盾的证据；而在自我怀疑的情况下，过去再多的证明你很有才华的证据，似乎也无法说服你相信你的恐惧是没有根据的。不，我的意思是，这绝对是对的。事实上，这几乎让我想起了社会心理学中的概念——确认偏误。你知道，你更倾向于寻找支持相反观点的证据，也就是支持你不够能干这一观点的证据，尽管你的成就明明表明并非如此。所以我确实能看出其中的联系。自我怀疑还有一个最后的维度，我想把它提出来。演员汤姆·汉克斯
long been one of Hollywood's biggest stars, but like Viola Davis, he has said that he also worries that he is soon going to be found out. No matter who we are, no matter what we've done, there comes a point where you think, how did I get here and am I going to be able to continue this? When are they going to discover that I am in fact a fraud and take everything away from me? It's a high wire act that we all walk and I do this in the work that I do because there are days when I know that three o'clock tomorrow afternoon, I
长期以来一直是好莱坞最大的明星之一，但和维奥拉·戴维斯一样，他也曾表示，他同样担心自己很快就会被人识破。无论我们是谁，无论我们做过什么，总会有那么一个时刻，你会想：我是怎么走到这一步的？我还能继续下去吗？他们什么时候才会发现其实我就是个骗子，然后把我拥有的一切都夺走？这是我们所有人都在走的走钢丝表演，我在自己的工作中也会这样，因为有些日子我知道，明天下午三点，
am going to have to deliver some degree of emotional goods. And if I can't do it, that means I'm going to have to fake it. And if I fake it, that means they may catch me at faking it. And if they catch me at faking it, well, then it's just doomsday. What strikes me in this clip, Kevin, is another dimension of self-doubt, and we've discussed this elsewhere in Hidden Brain. Many of us subject ourselves to the kind of scrutiny and criticism we would never dream of aiming at other people. Can you talk a moment about the harshness of our inner critic? You know, are you yourself harder on you than you are on other people? I think that's a really good question. I know that certainly I can see elements of that in myself.
我必须交付一定程度的情感货色。如果我做不到，那就意味着我必须伪装。如果我伪装了，那就意味着他们可能会抓包我的伪装。如果他们抓包了我的伪装，好吧，那简直就是世界末日了。凯文，这段话让我震撼的是自我怀疑的另一个维度，我们在《隐藏的大脑》的其他地方也讨论过这一点。我们许多人对自己实施的那种审视和批判，是我们做梦也想不到会用在别人身上的。你能谈谈我们内心批评者的苛刻吗？你知道，你自己是不是对自己比对别人更严厉？我认为这是一个非常好的问题。我知道我当然能在自己身上看到这种元素的影子。
When I've done something that is noteworthy for which I should be proud of, and nevertheless, I can still find reasons to be critical of it, to find reasons to not be as happy or bido or excited about it, to find reasons to not be as happy or by the or excited by the or two sort of embrace it as a worthy accomplishment. And so being our own harsh critics, that's something that I see that I can hear in what Tom Hanks said, and certainly I can see elements of that in myself. Yeah. There's a theme that runs through many of the examples of imposter phenomenon that we've
当我做了一件值得注意、本该为此感到骄傲的事情时，然而，我依然能找到理由去批评它，找到理由不去为之感到那么高兴、振奋或兴奋，找到理由不去为之感到那么高兴、振奋或兴奋，或者去将它拥抱为一项当之无愧的成就。因此，成为我们自己严厉的批评者，这是我从汤姆·汉克斯所说的话中看到并听到的，而且我当然也能在自己身上看到这种元素的影子。是的。在我们讨论过的许多冒名顶替现象的例子中，有一个贯穿始终的主题。
discussed. Maya Angelo, sort of written Levin Books, thinks that she's a fraud. The writer John Steinbeck is supposed to have once written something very similar. He wrote, I'm not a writer. I've been fooling myself and other people. And even the physicist Albert Einstein is supposed to have once called himself an involuntary swindler. Now on the surface, all of this seems incomprehensible.
玛雅·安杰洛写了十一本书，却觉得自己是个骗子。作家约翰·斯坦贝克据说也曾写过非常类似的话。他写道：“我不是作家。我一直在欺骗自己和别人。”甚至物理学家阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦也曾一度称自己为“非自愿的骗子”。表面上看，这一切似乎都不可理喻。
You know, you've written amazing books, if you've reinvented the world of physics, how can you think of yourself as a cheat and a swindler? Why do you think it is that people who are plagued by self-doubt cannot see the brilliance that is playing for us to see when we look in from the outside? You know, I mean, I think that's the million dollar question. I mean, that's something that we are still in many ways trying to figure out. But what I will say is that if you've come from environments where you were sort of complimented on things unrelated to your intelligence, let's say that you were someone who was very socially skilled, let's say you were someone who was very sort of athletic.
你知道的，如果你写了出色的书，如果你重塑了物理学世界，你怎么会认为自己是个骗子和大盗呢？为什么你认为那些饱受自我怀疑困扰的人，却看不到当我们从局外人角度看时显而易见的才华呢？你知道，我的意思是，我认为这是价值百万美元的问题。我的意思是，这仍然是我们一直在试图弄清楚的事情。但我会说的是，如果你来自这样一个环境：你在那些与你的智力无关的事情上受到了赞美，比方说你是一个社交能力很强的人，比方说你是一个很有运动天赋的人。
And all you ever heard from people, family and friends was about your prowess in those areas, but you never received feedback about your intelligence. Then part of that can result in you internalizing this idea that, maybe you're not that smart, maybe you're telling us lie elsewhere, that's part of the origins of these feelings. Even the most successful people among us doubt their abilities from time to time. Self-doubt can be so powerful that it makes us feel like frauds in our own lives.
而你从家人和朋友那里听到的，全都是关于你在这些领域的杰出表现，但你从未收到过关于你智力的反馈。那么，这部分原因可能会导致你内化这样一种观点：也许你没那么聪明，也许你在其他地方说了谎，这就是这些感觉的根源的一部分。在我们中间，即使是最成功的人，也会时常怀疑自己的能力。自我怀疑的力量如此强大，以至于让我们觉得自己生活中的骗子。
When we come back, the origins are self-doubt and what we can do about that negative voice in our heads. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Lots of smart, talented, accomplished people harbor self-doubt. They worry they are frauds and impostors, even when they have ample evidence, there is no need for such fear. At the University of Michigan, psychologists Kevin Coakley studies the psychology of self-doubt and the imposter phenomenon. Kevin, the psychologist Pauline Clans and Suzanne Eimes first used the term imposter phenomenon in a 1978 study and they
休息之后，我们将探讨自我怀疑的根源，以及我们能对脑海中那个负面声音做些什么。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。许多聪明、有才华、有成就的人都心存自我怀疑。他们担心自己是骗子和冒牌货，即使他们有充分的证据表明根本没有必要有这种恐惧。在密歇根大学，心理学家凯文·科克利研究自我怀疑的心理学和冒名顶替现象。凯文，心理学家保琳·克兰斯和苏珊·埃姆斯在1978年的一项研究中首次使用了“冒名顶替现象”这个词，他们
focused on high achieving women. Can you describe that study for me and what they found? These were women who were all incredibly accomplished women. And it was interesting because when they worked with them, they kept repeatedly hearing these feelings of self-doubt in spite of the accomplishments that they had as individual women. And so they led them to theorize that this idea of the imposter phenomenon was something that they believed at the time salient among women.
把重点放在了高成就女性身上。你能为我描述一下那项研究以及他们的发现吗？这些女性都是极其成功的女性。有趣的是，当他们与这些女性合作时，他们不断地、反复地听到这些女性在表达自我怀疑的感觉，尽管她们作为个人已经取得了种种成就。因此，这促使他们提出理论，认为这种冒名顶替现象的概念是他们当时认为在女性中非常显著的一种现象。
Because again, this was the population they were working with. Now the examples of people like Tom Hanks or Albert Einstein and you yourself, Kevin, might suggest the imposter phenomenon doesn't just affect women. Is that data to back up the anecdotes? That's absolutely true. I mean, in my own work, I have public studies where in one study, imposter feelings were certainly more prevalent among women than men, but in another study that I published, there was no difference between men and women.
因为这毕竟是他们当时合作的人群。现在，像汤姆·汉克斯、阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦以及你自己（凯文）这样的人的例子，可能表明冒名顶替现象不仅仅影响女性。有没有数据来支持这些轶事呢？这绝对是真的。我的意思是，在我自己的研究中，我发表过这样的研究：在一项研究中，冒名顶替的感觉在女性中确实比男性更普遍；但在我发表的另一项研究中，男女之间并没有差异。
And what we know from the accumulation of work that's been done in this area is that there has not been any consistent findings of women experiencing, you know, higher and positive feelings than men. Now, that being said, and I talk about this a lot, I do believe that with women, that the implications of imposter feelings are a bit different than among men.
从在该领域积累的大量研究中我们知道，并没有任何一致的研究结果表明女性经历的冒名顶替感比男性更高。话虽如此，我经常谈到这一点，我确实相信，对于女性而言，冒名顶替感觉的含义与男性略有不同。
And I point to one of the studies that I published where I was looking at factors that predict GPA. And what I found in that study was that even though there were no differences between men and women in terms of their imposter feelings, imposter feelings had no link to GPA for men. It did not impact their grades at all. But for women, imposter feelings were, in fact, linked in very sort of clear ways to their
我指出我发表过的一项研究，其中我考察了预测平均绩点（GPA）的因素。我在那项研究中发现，尽管男女在冒名顶替的感觉上没有差异，但对于男性来说，冒名顶替的感觉与GPA没有任何联系。它根本没有影响他们的成绩。但对于女性来说，冒名顶替的感觉确实以非常明确的方式与她们的
GPA. So you can say on the one hand that there were no differences in the reporting of imposter feelings amongst both groups, but the implications of those imposter feelings were quite different for men and women. What about racial differences here, Kevin? We've talked about several prominent black people who experienced self-doubt, but you've conducted studies looking at racial differences in self-doubt, and some of the results are both revealing and surprising.
GPA挂钩。所以你可以一方面说，这两个群体在报告冒名顶替感觉方面没有差异，但这些冒名顶替感觉对男性和女性的含义却大不相同。凯文，这里的种族差异又如何呢？我们讨论了几位经历过自我怀疑的杰出黑人，但你做过研究来探讨自我怀疑中的种族差异，其中一些结果既具有启发性又令人惊讶。
What do you find? So in the initial study that I published, we had a very diverse sample of college students consisting of Asian Americans, African Americans, and Latinx Americans. And we went into the study thinking that we would see evidence of higher and positive feelings among African-Americans and Latinx Americans. And we believe that because of what we understand to be some of the ideas and beliefs surrounding African-American students and Latinx students around intelligence and around their
你发现了什么？因此在我们发表的最初研究中，我们有一个非常多元的大学生样本，包括亚裔美国人、非裔美国人和拉丁裔美国人。我们在进行研究时认为，我们会看到非裔美国人和拉丁裔美国人表现出更高水平的冒名顶替感的证据。我们之所以这样认为，是因为我们理解到围绕非裔美国学生和拉丁裔学生在智力方面以及他们
deservedness to be in some predominant white educational spaces. But what we found, in some predominant white educational spaces. But what we found, in fact, was quite the opposite. We found that Asian American students in our particular sample reported higher fillings of imposterism than both African American students and Latinx students. And this was counterintuitive to what we expected to find. And we tried to explain it somewhat speculatively on the idea that
是否配得上在某些以白人为主的教育空间中存在的一些观念和信念。但事实上，我们发现的结果恰恰相反。我们发现，在我们这个特定的样本中，亚裔美国学生报告的冒名顶替感比非裔美国学生和拉丁裔美国学生都要高。这与我们的预期背道而驰。我们试图对此做出某种推测性的解释，认为是
Asian American students are, you know, have to sort of deal with that modern minority myth in ways that sort of exacerbate those feelings. I mean, it might be a little bit like what we discussed earlier about Viola Davis basically saying, you know, other people think that I'm perfect, but I know I'm not perfect, and that creates a kind of dissonance in my mind. Yes, absolutely. You hinted at something a moment ago, and I'm wondering if we can explore this a little bit more, which is there seems to be a connection between highly competitive environments
亚裔美国学生，你知道的，必须以某种会加剧这些感觉的方式来应对“模范少数族裔神话”。我的意思是，这可能有点像我们之前讨论过的维奥拉·戴维斯的观点，基本上是说，你知道，别人认为我很完美，但我知道自己并不完美，这在我的脑海中产生了一种认知失调。是的，完全如此。你刚才暗示了一点，我想知道我们是否可以对此做进一步的探讨，那就是高度竞争的环境
and the internal generation of self-doubt. You talk, for example, about walking down the corridors at your first job and seeing the publications of other professors in the wall. And in some ways, having this be a reminder for you that you had not done as much. Can you talk about the link between being in a competitive environment and the experience of self-doubt?
与内心产生自我怀疑之间似乎存在着某种联系。例如，你谈到走过你第一份工作的走廊，看到墙上其他教授的出版物。在某种程度上，这成了提醒你做得还不够的一个提醒。你能谈谈身处竞争激烈的环境与自我怀疑的体验之间的联系吗？
When you are in environments that are stressful and that are particularly competitive, these almost become incubators for these imposter feelings. Again, if I use myself as an example, you know, the story that you shared about me being a 29 year old professor, straight out of graduate school, it was a competitive environment. Part of it, I think, may have been just my own internalization because it wasn't like I had my colleagues coming to me and constantly reminding me, you know you are in a competitive environment, you know you have to do this. No, it wasn't anything so explicit. But it was just the subtle reminders that you are now a professor in a very productive, competitive environment and they didn't have to say anything to me.
当你处于充满压力且竞争异常激烈的环境中时，这些环境几乎就成了这些冒名顶替感觉的孵化器。再次以我自己为例，你知道，你分享的关于我29岁刚从研究生院毕业就当上教授的故事，那是一个竞争激烈的环境。部分原因，我认为可能只是我自己的内化，因为并不是说我的同事来到我面前不断提醒我，你知道你处在一个竞争激烈的环境中，你知道你必须这样做。不，没有什么那么明确的事情。但这只是微妙的提醒：你现在是一个高产、竞争激烈的环境中的教授，而他们甚至不需要对我说什么。
I was reminded by those publications that I saw on the walls. You know, you've talked about another idea about how we communicate with young people, especially in educational settings. If you communicate to a young person, you know, I think you're a genius, I think you're a prodigy, I think you're special. In some ways, we might think that we are communicating encouragement to the person, but
我被我在墙上看到的那些出版物提醒了。你知道的，你曾讨论过另一个关于我们如何与年轻人交流的想法，尤其是在教育环境中。如果你对一个年轻人交流说，你知道，我认为你是天才，我认为你是神童，我认为你很特别。在某些情况下，我们可能会认为我们是在向这个人传达鼓励，但
we're also putting expectations on that person. So when that person doesn't do well in a study or doesn't do well in a test, I mean, you know, they're now comparing their performance with what they believe you think of their performance and they feel like they're falling short. Is there a risk in some ways in overinflating, you know, the student's sense of how good they might be or how good they ought to be? I think there is a risk. I mean, there is nothing wrong with offering encouragement. I think all students need encouragement. But to your point, I do think that one could go overboard with the praise and set students up for struggling with these sort of feelings of self-doubt if the level of praise exceeds
我们也在给这个人施加期望。所以当这个人考试考砸了或者学习表现不佳时，我的意思是，你知道，他们现在正在将他们的表现与他们认为你对他们的表现的看法进行比较，他们觉得自己没有达到要求。在某种程度上，过度夸大（你知道的）学生对自己有多优秀或本该有多优秀的看法，是否存在风险？我认为确实存在风险。我的意思是，提供鼓励并没有错。我认为所有学生都需要鼓励。但就你的观点而言，我确实认为如果赞美程度超出了
what they either believe about themselves or maybe even exceeds what they have actually accomplished. I mean, I think that the deliverance of praise should be appropriate to the level of accomplishment and not do so in an exaggerated manner. So, some time ago we had the psychologist Claude Steele on Hidden Brain. It was in an episode titled How They See Us. And he talked about the phenomenon of stereotype threat. When you believe you're the target of stereotypes, those fears can be a source of worry and that worry can undermine your performance. There seems to be some overlap between your work on the imposter phenomenon and Claude's
他们对自己信念甚至超出了他们实际取得的成就，那么一个人可能会在赞美上做得过火，从而让学生在面对这些自我怀疑的情绪时陷入困境。我的意思是，我认为赞美的传达应该与成就的水平相匹配，而不应该以夸张的方式进行。那么，一段时间前，我们请心理学家克劳德·斯蒂尔（Claude Steele）上了《隐藏的大脑》。那一集名为《他们如何看我们》。他谈到了刻板印象威胁的现象。当你认为自己是刻板印象的目标时，这些恐惧就会成为担忧的来源，而这种担忧会损害你的表现。你对冒名顶替现象的研究与克劳德对刻板印象威胁的研究之间似乎有一些重叠。
work on stereotype threat. I was having this conversation two days ago and I was asked this very same question, you know, so it's something that I thought about for a while. And the way that I describe it is this. When you think about clouds deals working on stereotype threat, you know, it's this idea that individuals are aware of stereotypes that exist about once, a particular social identity group, whether that's based on race or gender or whatever. And you don't necessarily believe
我两天前还在进行这样的对话，当时有人问我同样的问题，所以这是我思考了一段时间的事情。我描述它的方式是这样的。当你想到克劳德·斯蒂尔关于刻板印象威胁的工作时，你知道，这就是这样一种观点：个人意识到了关于某个特定的社会认同群体存在的刻板印象，无论是基于种族、性别还是其他什么。你不一定相信
the stereotypes that exist about the group, but you are aware of them and it's the awareness of that stereotype that ends up disrupting your performance. That's different from in pasta feelings because within pasta feelings, we're talking about individuals who have internalized these beliefs that sort of lead to self-doubt.
存在于该群体身上的刻板印象，但你意识到了它们，正是对这种刻板印象的意识最终扰乱了你的表现。这与冒名顶替的感觉不同，因为在冒名顶替的感觉中，我们谈论的是那些内化了这些导致自我怀疑的信念的个人。
You found that self-doubt can be a predictor of stress, especially for minorities in educational settings. Can you talk about that work? Yeah, so one of the most common types of studies that you see done with the Impossible Nanomenite is looking at two outcomes related to mental health. You know, I tend to look at symptoms of depression and anxiety as my outcomes. And what we have consistently found is that
你发现自我怀疑可以成为压力的预测指标，特别是对于教育环境中的少数族裔而言。你能谈谈那项研究吗？是的，所以你在“冒名顶替现象”研究中最常看到的一种研究类型是观察与心理健康相关的两个结果。你知道，我倾向于将抑郁和焦虑的症状作为我的研究结果。而我们一致发现的是，
that individuals who experience in positive feelings have elevated symptoms of depression and have elevated symptoms of anxiety. They are certainly linked consistently. Is it accurate to say that women and minorities in the workplace or educational settings might be especially prone to this correlation? I believe that to be the case, absolutely. And I approach my work with the belief that for women and for bipock individuals, that this sort of association between mental health and imposter feelings
经历冒名顶替感觉的个人具有升高的抑郁症状和升高的焦虑症状。它们无疑是持续联系在一起的。说女性和少数族裔在工作场所或教育环境中可能特别容易受到这种相关性的影响，这准确吗？我认为情况确实如此，绝对如此。我带着这样的信念开展我的工作：对于女性和有色人种（BIPOC）个体而言，心理健康与冒名顶替感觉之间的这种关联
is especially prevalent. Self-doubt can keep us from seeing ourselves clearly. It can prompt us to downplay our accomplishments and underestimate our skills. It can prompt us to downplay our accomplishments and underestimate our skills. It can cost us in terms of mental health and in terms of our willingness to take on new challenges. But there is a deep paradox here. Even as lots of people suffer from needless self-doubt,
尤其普遍。自我怀疑会阻碍我们清晰地看清自己。它会促使我们贬低自己的成就，低估自己的技能。它会促使我们贬低自己的成就，低估自己的技能。它让我们在心理健康以及承担新挑战的意愿方面付出代价。但这里存在一个深刻的悖论。尽管许多人遭受着不必要的自我怀疑之苦，
many also suffer from an absence of self-doubt. Many people who ought to doubt themselves seem filled with blight self-confidence. When we come back, how to combat the imposter phenomenon, but also how to make room in our lives for the gift of self-doubt. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Even the best of us can sometimes feel we don't know what we are doing. We worry that we will fall short of other people's expectations.
许多人也遭受着缺乏自我怀疑之苦。许多本该怀疑自己的人似乎充满了盲目的自信。休息之后，我们将探讨如何对抗冒名顶替现象，以及如何在我们的生活中为自我怀疑这份“礼物”腾出空间。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们当中最好的人有时也会觉得自己不知道自己在做什么。我们担心自己达不到别人的期望。
We worry that we will be called out as frauds and shallotans. At the University of Michigan, psychologists Kevin Cochley studies the imposter phenomenon and what we can do about it. Kevin, one technique you've suggested that people use to reduce self-doubt is to remind themselves of their accomplishments. You say that you sometimes stalk yourself. What do you mean by this?
我们担心自己会被当成骗子和江湖郎中揭穿。在密歇根大学，心理学家凯文·科克利研究冒名顶替现象以及我们能做些什么。凯文，你建议人们用来减少自我怀疑的一种技术是提醒自己所取得的成就。你说你有时会“人肉”自己。你这是什么意思？
Yeah. So one of the things that happens with people who experience imposter feelings is is that we don't acknowledge accomplishments to the extent that they should be acknowledged. And so we sometimes just minimize them. And you know, I somewhat have jokingly said that I stalk myself. But, you know, what I mean is that, and I hope people out there listening don't judge me too harshly, I go on Google almost every day and I Google myself. I look up, you know, my metrics surrounding my publications, my publications, how many times I've been
是的。因此，经历冒名顶替感觉的人身上发生的事情之一，就是我们没有在应该被承认的程度上承认成就。所以我们有时只是把它们轻描淡写。你知道，我开玩笑地说过我“人肉”自己。但是，你知道，我的意思是，我希望正在收听的听众不要对我有太严厉的评判，我几乎每天都会上谷歌搜索我自己。我查阅，你知道的，围绕我的出版物的各种指标，我的出版物，我被引用的次数，
cited, how many publications I have. Those numbers don't change day to day, but I find myself looking at them every single day because I need to remind myself that people think that you're a big deal for a reason, that you actually have done something of note as a scholar. And so that's my way of just sort of reminding myself that you are deserving of the attention and the accolades that you have received. And if I didn't do that, then it would be easy to sort of forget that I have accomplished this
我有多少出版物。这些数字日复一日并没有改变，但我发现自己每天都在查看它们，因为我需要提醒自己，人们认为你是个大人物是有原因的，你作为一名学者确实做了一些值得注意的事情。所以这是我提醒自己“你配得上你所获得的关注和赞誉”的一种方式。如果我不这样做，那么我就很容易忘记我作为一名学者已经取得了这些成就。
as an academic. Yeah, I mean, I suppose it's the way you can Google yourself every day in order to stroke your vanity, but I think what I'm hearing you say is actually something quite different. It's almost like a cognitive behavioral therapy intervention because your mind is not automatically remembering all the things that you've done well or your mind is coming up with self-doubt. By actually going and looking at the evidence every day, you're in some ways telling your mind, look, the belief that I have that I'm not worthy or that I'm not up to this task, this belief is on true.
是的，我的意思是，我想这是你可以每天谷歌自己来满足虚荣心的一种方式，但我认为我听到你说的其实是完全不同的东西。这几乎就像是一种认知行为疗法干预，因为你的大脑不会自动记住所有你做好的事情，或者你的大脑会不断产生自我怀疑。通过实际去查看每天的证据，你在某种程度上是在告诉你的大脑：看，我认为自己不配或无法胜任这项任务的信念，这种信念是不真实的。
So in some ways, it feels almost like a form of therapy that you've come up with on your own. Well, it is. And I'm so glad that you mentioned the word vanity because I fear that what I just said come across as just someone obsessed, you know, worked himself and seeing, you know, what he's accomplished. And it's really not that, although I can understand how it might sound that way, because in my case, I really truly sometimes find it hard to accept the fact that I am somewhat of an authority on the impossible
所以在某种程度上，这感觉几乎像是你自己想出的一种治疗形式。嗯，确实如此。我很高兴你提到了“虚荣”这个词，因为我担心我刚才说的话会被当成是一个沉迷于自我、关注自己所取得成就的人。其实真不是这样，尽管我能理解为什么它听起来可能是那样，因为在我的情况中，我真的有时很难接受这样一个事实：我竟然是冒名顶替现象方面的某种权威。
nominat. And so when I go and look up sort of what I've done, like I sometimes actually forget how much work I've done in the area. And I hope that people don't sort of take that to be someone who's just unduly vain about his work and reading that way because I'd like to think that it is not that. Yeah, I'm not hearing that at all, Kevin. You know, you said a second ago that you find it hard to accept sometimes that you're an authority on the imposter phenomenon. You do see the irony here, right, Kevin, which is you're an expert on the imposter phenomenon, who finds it difficult to accept that you're an expert on the imposter phenomenon. I do difficult to accept that you are an expert on the imposter phenomenon? I do see the irony in that statement, yes. There's another idea that in some ways is a related idea, which is, you know, there are
所以当我去看自己做过的事情时，我有时甚至会忘记自己在该领域做过多少工作。我希望人们不要认为这是一个对自己的工作过分虚荣并以此进行阅读的人，因为我想认为事实并非如此。是的，凯文，我一点也没有那种感觉。你知道，你刚才说你有时发现自己很难接受你是冒名顶替现象的权威。你确实看到了其中的讽刺意味，对吧，凯文？也就是说，你是一个冒名顶替现象的专家，却发现很难接受自己是冒名顶替现象的专家。我确实看到了这种说法中的讽刺意味，是的。还有一个在某种程度上相关的想法，那就是，你知道，有
people whose accomplishments are not public, you know, they don't have publication records, they don't have awards, but in some ways these people can mind the same idea that you're talking about with something called a work diary. Can you explain that idea to me? Yeah, so you know one of the other suggestions that I give to people is to keep a work diary where you essentially document those successes that you've had in the work environment. What ends up happening for people who experience and positive feelings is that it becomes very easy for us to just sort of either forget or to minimize or marginalize those things that we've done well during the course of a day,
那些成就没有公开的人，你知道的，他们没有发表记录，没有得过奖，但在某种程度上，这些人可以通过一种叫做工作日志的东西来梳理你刚才谈论的那个想法。你能向我解释一下那个想法吗？好的，我给人们的另一个建议是写一份工作日志，在其中基本上记录你在工作环境中取得的成功。对于那些经历过积极情绪的人来说，最后往往会发生这样的情况：我们很容易在一天、
during the course of a week. And so sometimes we have to be intentional about documenting those little successes that in the aggregate are pretty impressive. So Kevin, we've talked about ways that individuals can manage their self-doubt. Are the things that organizations can do that can also reduce self-doubt? Yes, there certainly are things that organizations can do. And the example that I like to give involves individuals who are managers, you know, or supervisors. And what you can do as a manager or a supervisor to really sort of mitigate
一周的过程中，忘记、淡化或边缘化那些我们做得好的事情。因此，有时我们需要刻意记录下那些微小的成功，这些成功加起来其实相当令人印象深刻。凯文，我们讨论了个人如何管理自我怀疑的方法。组织是否也能做一些事情来减少自我怀疑呢？是的，组织当然可以做一些事情。我喜欢举的例子涉及那些担任管理者或主管的个人。作为一名管理者或主管，你真正能做的事情，是为了减轻
these sort of feelings of imposterism amongst your subordinates is being transparent in your own vulnerabilities and to be open and sharing this with their employees. It really helps individuals who are afraid to own up or to sort of say, I've made a mistake. It makes them feel like, you know what, if my manager or if my supervisor can talk openly about making the mistake, then it's okay for me to make a mistake and I don't have to be perfect.
你的下属中存在的这种冒名顶替感，就是在你自己的脆弱性方面保持透明，并且公开并与你的员工分享这一点。这确实对那些害怕承认或说出“我犯了个错误”的人很有帮助。这让他们觉得，你知道吗，如果我的经理或主管可以公开谈论犯错误，那么我犯错误也是可以的，我不必做到完美。
And I think that goes a long way towards helping to assuage any feelings of imposterism that an individual might be experiencing. Researchers have also looked at ways to dismantle the imposter phenomenon in schools. At Stanford University, Greg Walton looked at the problems that incoming freshmen were facing. And he found that when the experience setbacks, many of them drew global conclusions like, you know, I don't belong here, or I don't deserve to be here. And he felt like blacks were especially likely to feel like they were frauds.
我认为这在很大程度上长远来看有助于平息个人可能体验到的任何冒名顶替感。研究人员还探讨了在学校中消除冒名顶替现象的方法。在斯坦福大学，格雷格·沃尔顿（Greg Walton）研究了新生们面临的问题。他发现，当他们经历挫折时，许多人会得出全局性的结论，比如“我不属于这里”或者“我不配呆在这里”。他觉得黑人尤其倾向于觉得自己是骗子。
And so he set up an intervention that helped black students see setbacks in the proper perspective. So a bad test result or a bad interaction with a professor didn't mean that they were frauds, it didn't mean they were imposter, it just meant that they were having, you know, a bad day or a bad week. Here's a clip of Greg describing the effects of his intervention. What the intervention did was it prevented students from feeling that they didn't belong in general when they had negative experiences. You can then imagine how if you're feeling
因此，他设立了一项干预措施，帮助黑人学生以正确的视角看待挫折。因此，一次糟糕的考试结果或与教授的不愉快互动并不意味着他们是骗子，也不意味着他们是冒名顶替者，这只意味着他们度过了一个糟糕的日子或糟糕的一周。这里有一段格雷格描述他的干预措施效果的剪辑。这项干预措施所做的是，当学生有负面经历时，它防止了他们产生一般意义上不属于这里的这种感觉。你可以想象，如果你觉得自己
less vulnerable to threats, you are better able to connect with other people, to peers, to teachers, and build the kinds of relationships that actually sustain performance over a long period of time. Kevin, I'm wondering if you can weigh in on this. Is one solution to self-doubt in some ways not blowing things out of proportion, blowing setbacks out of proportion? I love that, and I'm thank you for sharing that study. You know, as a council psychologist, I would sort of refer to that as almost like, I'm simply reframing it and not sort of internalizing it as being indicative of a trait about yourself.
对威胁不那么脆弱，你就更能与其他人、同龄人、老师建立联系，并建立那种实际上能在长期内维持绩效的关系。凯文，我想知道你对此有什么看法？解决自我怀疑的一个办法，在某种程度上是不是不要把事情夸大，不要把挫折夸大呢？我喜欢这个说法，谢谢你分享那个研究。你知道的，作为一名咨询心理学家，我差不多会把它称为，我只是在重新构架它，而不是把它内化为关于你自身某种特质的指示。
People aren't perfect. And we have to sort of get beyond this idea that making mistakes is somehow indicative of you being not smart, not competent, not belonging. The most accomplished people in the world have all experienced failure at some point. And so we need to sort of help students in particular understand that when you've failed a test, and I could have been if it were from this, when I was a student, it would have
人无完人。我们必须超越这样一种观念，即犯错误在某种程度上表明你不够聪明、不够能干、不属于这里。世界上最有成就的人在某个时刻都经历过失败。因此，我们需要帮助学生，尤其是学生，去理解当你考试不及格时——如果从这方面来说，当我还是个学生时，如果能有一位教授把我拉到一边，
been so helpful if I would have had a professor who would have pulled me to the side and to help me sort of manage the feelings that I was having around my initial sort of early poor performance. It's okay. Just don't let it be defining of who you are and what your potential reality is. And I think we don't have enough of that taking place in schools. You know, Kevin, we started this conversation talking about some of your own insecurities and self-doubt.
帮助我处理我围绕最初的早期糟糕表现所产生的感受，那将是多么有帮助啊。这没关系。只是不要让它定义你是谁以及你的潜在现实是什么。我认为我们在学校里没有进行足够这样的交流。你知道，凯文，我们在开始这次对话时谈到了你的一些不安全感和自我怀疑。
When you are plagued by self-doubt, even today, you see that you have a go-to solution and it involves effort. Can you explain what you do, maybe with a specific example? Yeah, well, and I'll start off by, you know, going back to Michelle Obama. Michelle Obama says that what she does is essentially, you know, she works hard. I mean, she works harder. So whenever I doubted myself, I just told myself,
当你被自我怀疑所困扰时，即使在今天，你也会发现你有一个首选的解决方案，它涉及到付出努力。你能解释一下你是怎么做的吗，也许可以用一个具体的例子？好的，嗯，我首先要说的是，回顾一下米歇尔·奥巴马。米歇尔·奥巴马说她所做的基本上是，你知道的，她努力工作。我的意思是，她工作更努力。所以每当我怀疑自己时，我只是告诉自己，
let me put my head down and do the work, and I would let my work speak for itself. And I still find that I do that. And I really identify with that because that has been the way that I try to address my feelings of imposterism. When I think about those early days of my being an assistant professor, I would work late in the evenings. I found myself working on the weekends because I needed
让我埋头苦干，做好工作，我会让我的工作自己说话。我发现自己现在仍然这样做。我对此深有共鸣，因为这就是我试图应对我的冒名顶替感的方式。当我回想我担任助理教授的早期日子时，我会工作到深夜。我发现自己在周末也在工作，因为我需要
to prove to people and I think probably most importantly to myself that I belong. And so I just I worked incessantly. Now I will say that hard work without having a way to sort of balance that with play is not necessarily a good thing, but what I will say is that hard work, oftentimes, you know, can result in achieving an accomplishment in ways that you would hope would help mitigate whatever feelings of apostorism you might be experiencing. Do you still do that even today, Kevin? Is this your response
向人们证明，并且我认为可能最重要的是向我自己证明，我是属于这里的。所以我只是不停地工作。现在我要说的是，没有通过某种方式将之与玩耍平衡起来的努力工作不一定是件好事，但我要说的是，努力工作往往能够带来成就，以你希望的方式帮助减轻你可能经历的任何冒名顶替感。凯文，直到今天你还在这样做吗？当有人请你去做演讲，或者你必须做一个大型演讲，而你又被自我怀疑所困扰时，
when someone asks you to give a talk or you have to make a big presentation and you're and you're plagued with self-doubt? Do you respond to that by doubling down on the amount of time you're spending in preparation? You know there are elements of that. When Pauline Clancy Susan and I think it was really Pauline Clancy, she talked about the imposter, and she talked about these two pathways that people take. The pathway of over-paradness and the pathway of procrastination, and I'm the person who goes through the pathway of over-paradness. And for me, what that means is, when I am giving a talk on the imposter phenomenon,
这就是你的反应吗？你对这种状况的反应是加倍投入准备时间吗？你知道，其中有这方面的元素。当波琳·克兰西（Pauline Clancy）——苏珊和我，我想真的就是波琳·克兰西，她谈到了冒名顶替者，她谈到了人们采取的两条途径。过度准备的途径和拖延的途径，而我就是走过度准备途径的那个人。对我来说，这意味着，当我做一个关于冒名顶替现象的演讲时，
a talk that I have given more times than I can count. I still prepare as though I have never given the talk before. And it's because I want to make sure that when I give the talk that people hear me and experience me as being an expert and leave no doubt in their mind that I know what I'm talking about. So yeah, there's still elements of that in me even today. You know, I'm struck by what you just said, Kevin, because when I listen to that clip of
一个我已经讲过无数次的演讲。我依然像从未讲过这个演讲一样去准备。这是因为我想确保当我做演讲时，人们听到我、感受到我是一个专家，并在他们心中不留任何疑问地知道我在说什么。所以是的，直到今天我身上仍然有这方面的元素。你知道，我被你刚才所说的话深深打动了，凯文，因为当我听维奥拉·戴维斯（Viola Davis）谈论那种觉得自己像个冒名顶替者的剪辑时，我没有把整个剪辑放给你听。她接着说了一件非常有趣的事情，你知道的，她没有说，哦，我好惨，我有这么多的不安全感，请同情我。她谈到她如何将自己的不安全感作为一种驱动力、一种动力。任何想要变得伟大的人都有这个。任何人，任何电影制片人、任何作家、任何演员，
Viola Davis talk about, you know, feeling like an imposter, I didn't play the whole clip for you. She goes on to say something really interesting, which is, you know, she doesn't say, you know, what was me, I have all these insecurities, feel sorry for me. She talks about how she uses her insecurities as a driver, as motivation. Anybody who even wants to be great has that. Anybody, any filmmaker, any writer, any actor,
但它在健康的层面上的作用是，它让你保持谦逊，让你不断工作。我听到的几乎正是你刚才对我说的话，凯文，也就是在某种程度上，不相信关于你的正面报道，实际上最终会成为一个强大的动力，促使你脚踏实地、努力工作（如果你愿意这么说的话），并且不把任何事情视为理所当然。你知道，维奥拉·戴维斯太有洞察力了。我的意思是，她完全正确。我要说的是，她所说的话绝对适用于我。我认为谦逊非常重要。
but what it does on a healthy level, it keeps you humble and it keeps you working. I'm hearing almost exactly what you said to me a second ago, Kevin, which is that in some ways, not believing the good press about you, turns out to actually be a powerful motivator for you to actually put your nose to the grindstone, if you will, and not take anything for granted. You know, Viola Davis is so insightful. I mean, she is absolutely correct. And I would say that what she has said definitely applies to me. I think humility is very important.
如果我有一天达到了失去谦逊的地步，我的妻子——她也是一名心理学博士——会把我拉回现实。她会迅速把我唤醒。我知道你赢了。我认为这是必要的，因为我永远不想达到那种地步，即我忘记了我曾那个发表了一篇论文、充满自我怀疑、开始自己职业生涯的年轻助理教授。我永远不想忘记那个人，因为那个个人仍然在我内心深处，它继续推动并激励我成为我所能成为的最好的学者。
And if I ever got to the point where I lost my humility, I would be brought back to Earth by my wife, who's also a Deku David. She would quickly revive me up. I knew you win. And I think that's necessary because I never want to get to the point where I have forgotten that I was that that younger sister professor was one publication and and full of self-doubt started my career. I never wanted to forget that I was that that younger sister professor was one publication and and full of self doubts started my career. I never want to forget that person because that person is still inside of me and it continues to fuel me and motivate me to being the best academic that I can be.
凯文，我在想，在某种程度上，这是否至少是我们对话第一部分中指出的那个悖论的部分解决方案。你知道，我们看到许多像玛雅·安杰洛（Maya Angelou）或阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦（Albert Einstein）这样才华横溢的人如何一直被自我怀疑所困扰，从外表来看这显得很诡异，但有没有可能我们实际上把因果关系搞混了？他们并不是在很伟大的同时还被自我怀疑所困扰。他们的伟大至少在一定程度上是由自我怀疑的燃料所驱动的。
I'm wondering in some ways, Kevin, whether this might be at least a partial solution to the paradox we identified in the first part of our conversation. You know, we looked at how many brilliant people like Maya Angelou or Albert Einstein have been plagued by self-doubt from the outside that looks bizarre, but is it possible that we actually have mixed up cause and effect? They are not plagued by self-doubt in spite of being great. Their greatness is being driven at least in part by the fuel of self-doubt. being driven at least in part by the fuel of self-doubt. Hmm. I think you're right. I think that is very much a possibility that their self-doubt in part fuels their greatness. I think there's an argument to be made for that. I'm wondering if it might be helpful almost for a moment to think about what would happen
嗯。我想你是对的。我认为这很有可能，他们的自我怀疑在一定程度上推动了他们的伟大。我认为这完全说得通。我在想，如果去思考一下，如果我们生活在一个没有自我怀疑的世界里，会发生什么，这会不会在某种程度上有那么一瞬间是有益的？我在回想2003年美国入侵伊拉克，你知道，布什政府说入侵是必要的，因为伊拉克正在开发大规模杀伤性武器。在一次新闻发布会上，时任国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德被告知伊拉克政府否认拥有大规模杀伤性武器。让我播放一段那个新闻发布会的剪辑。你对伊拉克政府昨天发表的关于伊拉克没有大规模杀伤性武器且未在开发的声明有何看法？他们在撒谎。
if we lived in a world without self-doubt. I'm thinking back to the US invasion of Iraq in 2003, you know, the Bush administration said the invasion was necessary because Iraq was developing weapons of mass destruction. And in one press conference, Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld was told that the Iraqi government had denied possessing weapons of mass destruction. Let me play a clip of that press conference. What do you make of the statement made by the Iraqi government yesterday that Iraq has no weapons of mass destruction and is not developing it? They're lying.
不，他们有，他们还在继续开发，他们已经将化学武器武器化了。我们知道他们曾有一个积极开发核武器的计划。因此同样清楚的是，他们正在积极开发生物武器。因此正如我们所知，凯文，伊拉克并没有那些武器。我想请你谈谈这个看起来像是悖论的问题。
No, they have them and they continue to develop them and they have weaponized chemical weapons. We know that they've had an active program to develop nuclear weapons. So it's also clear that they are actively developing biological weapons. So as we know, Kevin, Iraq did not possess those weapons. And I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about what seems like this paradox.
为什么我们中的一些人被自我怀疑所困扰，而另一些人却本来可以多一点自我怀疑呢？你知道，这是一个非常好的问题，它立刻让我想起了一句俗语，骄傲发生在灭亡之前，我想到当自负阻碍我们做出合理和理性决策的能力时会发生什么。我认为，有一点自我怀疑可以把我们从非常糟糕的境地中拯救出来，比如不必要的战争等事情。因此，如果拉姆斯菲尔德能表现出比他的回应所显示的更多的谦逊，那当然会很好。但是不，我的意思是，我喜欢你将这一点与现实世界的含义联系起来的方式。对我来说，这确实又回到了这样一种观念，即人们对自己不要过于自信，因为那种过于自信是没有帮助的、不健康的。
How is it that some of us are plagued with self-doubt while others could use a little more self-doubt? You know, that is a very good question and it immediately sort of reminded me of the saying, you know, pride followed before the man and I think about what happens when when hubris gets in the way of our ability to make reasoned and reasonable sort of decisions. And I think that having a bit of self-taught could save us from really bad situations such as unnecessary wars among other things. And so it certainly would have been nice if Rumsfeld had exhibited a bit more humility than his response indicated. But no, I mean, I think I like the way that you sort of
我怎么强调都不为过，在我的生活中，保持谦逊、甚至产生自我怀疑的感觉是多么有益。因为如果我没有那种自我怀疑的感觉，那么我认为这首先会使我可能成为一个让人难以忍受的人，一个相处起来不太愉快的人。但它也让我保持着渴望，继续努力工作来证明自己。我想，你知道的，当你到了开始想要证明自己却不再充满渴望和动力的时候，我认为那并不是一个很好的状态。
connected that to real-world implications. And to me, it does sort of go back to this idea of people idea of people not feeling so overly confident in themselves in ways that are unhelpful and are unhealthy. I can't say enough about how in my own life the need to be humble, to even have feelings of self-doubt have been helpful. Because if I did not have those feelings of self-doubt, then I think that that would one make me probably an unbearable person and not very pleasant to be around. But it also has kept me, I think, hungry to continue to work hard to prove myself. And I think, you know, when you get to the point where you start wanting to prove yourself and you're no longer hungry and motivated, I don't think that's a very good place to be.
所以我感觉我们正在探讨一个非常深刻的话题，凯文。一方面，我们看到经历歧视、作为局外人会增加你体验到冒名顶替现象的风险。这显然是不公平的。你知道的，自我怀疑的感觉会导致人们辍学，导致他们放弃本可以做得很好的职业。另一方面，许多人也将他们的不安全感转化为超能力，就像你一样，他们把它当作燃料，
So I feel we're in very deep waters here, Kevin. I mean, on the one hand, we've seen how experiencing discrimination, being an outsider, this can increase the risk that you will experience the imposter phenomenon. And that's clearly unfair. You know, feelings of self-doubt can cause people to drop out of school, cause them to quit professions that they would be great at. On the other hand, lots of people also turn their insecurity into a superpower like yourself, and they use it as fuel,
而缺乏自我怀疑，尤其是当你手握大权时，会产生可怕的危害。所以我想我禁不住在想，自我怀疑究竟是一件坏事还是一件好事呢？当自我怀疑被用作取得成就、追求卓越的动力来源时，它是一件好事，但它也可能以牺牲一个人的心理健康和身体健康为巨大代价。因此，你知道的，挑战就在于如何弄清楚如何以某种方式使用自我怀疑，
and a lack of self-doubt, especially when you wield great power can produce terrible harm. So I guess I'm left wondering, is self-doubt a bad thing or a good thing? Self-doubt can be a good thing when it is used as a source of motivation to achieve, to excel, but it can come at great cost to one's mental health and to one's physical health. And so, you know, the challenge then is to sort of figure out how to use oneself doubt in ways that
这种方式不会导致对你的心理健康或身体健康产生任何形式的损害。所以，你知道的，我有时与人们分享的例子，来自于非裔美国人心理学，我们在那里谈论约翰·亨利主义假设。这来自于一个故事，民间传说，一个名叫约翰·亨利的钢铁工人的故事，他基本上被置于一种与机器竞争表现的环境中。这个故事的简短版本是，
don't result in there being any sort of compromises to your mental health or physical health. And so, you know, the example that I, you know, sometimes share with people, you know, comes from African-American psychology where we talk about the John Henryism hypothesis. And this comes from a story, folklore, a story of an individual named John Henry who was a steel driver, who was essentially put in a situation where he was competing against a machine to perform. And the short version of the story is that
他想证明自己能够胜过这台机器。嗯，他工作，工作，再工作，最终他确实击败了机器。因此他的成就非常高，因为他赢了。但代价是他的生命，因为他最终因过度付出努力而力竭身亡。
he wanted to prove that he could outperform this machine. Well, he worked and he worked and he worked and he eventually did beat the machine. And so his achievement was quite high because he won. But it came at the cost of his life because he ended up dying from the exertion of effort that he gave. The last word that I heard that food boy said In the food bank of Water be quiet In the food bank of Water be quiet down In the food bank of Water be quiet down So we want to be careful that we don't achieve such incredible feats of accomplishment that also result in harming our mental health and our physical health. I'm gonna be a Steve Diamond man.
因此我们希望小心，不要取得如此令人难以置信的伟大成就，却同时也导致损害了我们的心理健康和身体健康。
In your own life, Kevin, have you come to think of self-doubt as a friend or as an enemy? Oh my goodness. That's a, you ask really difficult questions. Self-doubt, I think for me, I would say probably has been more of a friend than an enemy for me. I do try to take care of myself. I work out. I try to be healthy, but I have certainly used self-doubt in ways as a constant source of motivation to make
在你自己的生活中，凯文，你开始将自我怀疑视为朋友还是敌人？哦天哪。这是一个，你问的问题真的很难。自我怀疑，我想对我来说，可能会更多地是一个朋友而不是敌人。我确实试着照顾好自己。我锻炼。我努力保持健康，但我确实以某种方式将自我怀疑用作源源不断的动力，以确保
sure that I am not complacent. So I am aware of the things that I need to do to provide this sort of balance and that I continue to strive to be the best academic that I can be. So I think in my case, it has probably been more of a friend than an enemy. Kevin Cochley is a psychologist at the University of Michigan. He's the author of the myth of Black Anti-Intellectualism, a true psychology of African American students. Kevin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Ray. Thank you for having me. me today on Hidden Brain. If you have questions or thoughts about our conversation with Kevin Coakley and are willing
我不会自满。所以我清楚自己需要做哪些事情来提供这种平衡，并让我继续努力成为我能成为的最好的学者。所以我想在我的情况下，它可能更像是一个朋友而不是敌人。凯文·科克利（Kevin Cokley）是密歇根大学的心理学家。他是《黑人反智主义神话：非裔美国学生真实心理学》一书的作者。凯文，感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。
to have those questions shared with a larger Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasat HiddenBrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again, email the question to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org and use the subject line, Impostors. Hiddenbrain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
如果你对我们与凯文·科克利的对话有任何问题或想法，并且愿意与更广泛的《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。请记得附上你的姓名以及我们可以联系到你的电话号码。再次提醒，将问题通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，并使用主题行：冒名顶替者（Impostors）。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsunk hero this week is Hwana Meralo. Hwana is a graphic designer who created the Hidden Brain logo in 2015. When we launched our second podcast, My Unsunk Hero, we knew we wanted to work with Hwana again. She has an amazing eye as you will see if you take a look at the My Unsunk Hero logo. More than anything, Hwana cares deeply about what she does,
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Ani Murphy-Paul）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是霍瓦娜·梅拉洛（Hwana Meralo）。霍瓦娜是一位平面设计师，她在2015年创作了《隐藏的大脑》标志。当我们推出我们的第二个播客《我的无名英雄》（My Unsunk Hero）时，我们知道我们想再次与霍瓦娜合作。她有着令人惊叹的审美眼光，如果你看一看《我的无名英雄》的标志，你就会明白这一点。最重要的是，霍瓦娜对她所做的事情充满深情，
and that shows in her work. Thank you so much Hwana. Next week, we conclude our success 2.0 series with a look at creativity and how we can spark innovation in our own lives. Talent doesn't really seem to be the whole story, maybe a little bit of it, but not the whole story. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这在她的作品中得到了体现。非常感谢你，霍瓦娜。下周，我们将通过探讨创造力以及我们如何在自己的生活中激发创新，来结束我们的“成功2.0”系列。才华似乎并不是全部，也许只是一小部分，但绝不是全部。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。
See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。